Jordan Peterson is professor at the
University of Toronto he's written a lot
about the decline of modern men we spoke
to him recently certain Peterson thanks
for joining us we've got a long list of
statistics that paint a pretty clear
picture that boys seem to be falling
behind relative to girls in the United
States why do you think that is I think
that that's partly a consequence of
directed policy so it's it's linked to
the idea that there's something wrong
with masculinity and so that the
expression of masculinity should be
limited in in all sorts of arbitrary
ways the fact that kids can't really
play at schools anymore is a
manifestation of that the fact that male
behavior is often diagnosed as attention
deficit disorder for example as a
manifestation of that the the
elimination of competition as a valid
form of human interaction and the the
failure to recognize that competitive
sports for example are deeply
cooperative in their fundamental nature
as long as everyone is playing by the
rules obviously so there's that that
that's a large part of it what's so
you're saying that there is an organized
the not always explicit but still
organized attempt to de-emphasize
masculinity or to punish masculinity why
because because it's easy to mistake
masculine competence for the tyranny
that hypothetically drives the
patriarchy it's part of a ideological
worldview that sees the entire history
of mankind as the oppression of women by
men which is a dreadful way of looking
at the world a very pathological way of
looking at the world it's not like men
and women always get along any more than
men and men get along or women and women
for that matter but fundamentally human
history is a cooperative enterprise and
men and women have lifted themselves out
of the my
over millennia in their cooperative
endeavor and to describe that as
centuries of the oppression of men by of
women by men is an absolute absolutely
reprehensible ideological rewrite of
history and it's what's taught in the
humanities and in much of the social
sciences at universities and
increasingly in the public education
system it's taken has an unassailable
fact and you're saying that this has bad
consequences for the development of boys
well how could you feel good about that
I mean if you're if you're made out to
be what a potential manifestation of
rape culture if you're part of toxic
masculinity if you're competitive Drive
is regarded as part of a tyrannical
impulse if the heritage to which you are
to which you belong is regarded as an
oppressive patriarchy then how in the
world are you going to step forward with
confidence and shoulder that that that
that what would you call it that burden
why would you why wouldn't you just step
aside and retreat which is exactly
what's happening but if men are so
aggressive and bent on domination on
establishing a patriarchy why have they
stepped back and allowed this to happen
well I guess that's a good question
isn't it I don't know the answer to that
I don't know if they are precisely
allowing it to happen it's it's very
insidious the ideological movement
that's driving this part of the radical
left part of the radical left I would
say is it's very insidious movement it's
not an easy thing to resist and a lot of
it occurs well for example it occurs in
the school system increasingly and it
isn't clear what they're not men that
are reacting to that that's boys it's
not clear what they're supposed to do
about it so so if you it's already quite
an ideological battle it is it is hard
and finally if you were to give parents
of boys one piece of advice
for how in their small way they can
fight against this trend for the sake of
their own boys what would it be well I
would say first of all encourage them
and I mean that most deeply is that to
encourage someone is to instill courage
in them to support their courage and
that doesn't mean protect them from
what's dangerous it means teach them how
to be competent and teach them that they
can rely on themselves to prevail in
even in the darkest of circumstances
that's part of it I would say as well
more specifically and this is specific
advice for parents if you have your
children in a school and they talk about
equity and there's class and they talk
about equity diversity inclusivity white
privilege systemic racism any of that
you take your children out of the class
they're not being educated they're being
indoctrinated and there's absolutely no
excuse for it I agree with that
completely you might run out of schools
pretty quickly they'll here in this
country that would be just fine it's
hard to express my gratitude to you for
telling the truth as you do thank you
very much for that my pleasure